the number one thing i know that will
work for this audience is having a
foundation of two core things always
following the underpriced attention not
the mature attention when i tell you
everybody focuses on the mature
attention because it's easy it's what
you're stuck in instagram what are we
gonna do about a sustained content model
what we need to talk about is
underpriced attention why was i doing
email in 1997 for my dad's wine shop
because i had 93 open rates that's a
long time ago newsletter now gets 18
open rates why was i doing facebook fan
pages like ham in 2012 and 13. you know
why and then instagram and then this so
it's always moving if you're a real
business person like i am spending three
hours a day to make videos is not gonna
work for you you got family and you got
a business to run but can you do a
podcast once a week strictly for the 13
pieces of content it produces for you
because you film it and post produce it
all of you can because i'm busy as [ __ ]
and i do it 10 12 pieces of content a
day is the only answer to the thing
you're thinking about